hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the most mysterious game I've
ever seen the the game was sent to me
yesterday by by Goran radish and first I
thought he was tricking me or ordered
maybe just 24 speedy and Paige was wrong
or that some some you know wicked
sorcery was going on but then I checked
the other websites and the pigeon was
correct so here we have again from the
world a juniors championship for girls
that means you have to be under 20 years
old to participate and we have Greek
international master also women
Grandmaster stavroula Sol Aikido versus
India's women candidate master emerald a
hunka so it's it's a really crazy game
and this is one of the rare cases where
I do put the ratings of the players and
below their names as it really helps put
things into context so now I would also
like to mention that these are classical
games so ninety minutes per player for
40 moves and you are granted additional
time after reaching time control + 30
seconds per move you know you have you
get increment for for every move you
make so that being said let's check out
this mysterious game so so Aikido opens
with the white pieces
she plays efore and we have c6 by the
hanker the cork on defense sorry about
that
with d4 d5 and now II capture Sun defy
authority who goes for the for the
exchange variation of the caro-kann with
C captors and now just Bishop to d3 okay
we have nice the c6 attacking the d4
pawn we have c3 defending and now Queen
to c7 Knight to e2 this is all fairly
standard stuff Bishop to g4 developing
pinning the night I need to and white
castles we have e six now that the
bishop has been developed you can close
the the structure here and the Queen to
e1 unpinning now the knight can move
black continues development with Knight
to f6 and now f3 kicking the bishop back
with the ship to h5 and now Queen to h4
putting pressure on the bishop also
preparing Knight to f4 Bishop t4 is is
an idea so white has a lot of ideas on
how to continue development here and
here the hunker goes for rook to g8 it
makes
because for example if you Castle
queenside 94 you will want to play
Bishop Jesus but now after capturing you
will have to recapture with the F corner
which is not something you wanna do you
want to capture with the H pawn and the
rook on h8 will be a problem so rook the
g8 instead and now there are a couple of
moves that have been played in this
position Bishop to f4 has been played
Knight to f4 has been played here Bishop
to g5 has been played here but Bishop
captures on h7 is a new move and it is
as of move 11 that we have a completely
new game so point is white just wants to
win a pawn after Knight captures your
capture the bishop here has the knife no
longer guards that night will go back
you'll go back and you will enjoy your
extra pawn ensure black can claim that
maybe maybe he can claim this was a
sacrifice bunt but there really is no
merit to this the g5 square is already
nicely covered by the Queen and by the
bishop so there is no reason to do
something like this so instead after
Bishop captures an eight seven black
decided I want a pawn as well with
Bishop captures on f3 now of course if
rook captures and if 3d ideas just rook
to e8 where you will go after the bishop
there's a double attack on the bishop so
white will have to go for Rupe diverse
captures and then it's a it is a better
position for white but it's a really
weird position how will you with walk
your - apart of this situation so it's
it's probably possible but it's it
doesn't look all that great if the
bishop comes to d6 or black gets the
castle twin side if the other room gets
into the game could be very dangerous
for white so here after Bishop
characters on f3 we have Bishop captures
and g8 first now go shop capture Sonny -
you know it's a it's a capture fest and
rook captures on f6 will G captures on
f6 and now Queen captures on f6 and here
are just continuing development Bishop
to d6 now the idea is you will you will
try to bring the King somehow over to
the Queen's and get this rook end of the
game but for the moment it's not
possible the Queen is God is guarding
the f7 square so for the moment white
cannot capture here and here you should
just continue with Bishop to g5
continuing development that the knight
can come to d2 the rook can come into
the game but here white
King F do and it makes sense the bishop
is under attack you don't want it here
and only then will you continue your
development but it actually well this
this could lose the game for white white
played a black played Bishop to a6
however if Bishop to d3 was played then
it's just game over yeah your next move
is Queen to e7 and if the Queen's are
traded then you can just move the King
and you lose the bishop on g8 the bishop
on d3 covers the escape square for the
bishop so yeah you could try something
like Knight d2 but after Queen e7 like
we mentioned if you trade just King here
and the rook picks up the bishop or you
can try just moving somewhere to g7 but
then here you're really asking for
trouble Queen to h4 check now wherever
the King goes the bishop slices this way
Queen slices this way if you go to g1
than just Bishop captures on h2
everything is everything is just winning
here for black
so although Bishop to d3 is winning here
this is not why we're showing this game
butter up the a6 was played and now g3
not allowing this powerful battery to
have any influence on the King side
Queen to e7 now again with with a very
exciting idea of course if captures
captures then rush up to h7 will be met
with rock h8 and now if the bishop moves
you're gonna lose the h2 opponent it's
gonna be an overwhelming position for
black a but after Queen t7 we have Queen
to g7 just getting the Queen out of the
way and defending the the bishop after
the King moves with King to d7 by the
hunker and the now comes Bishop to h6
and here it's just a it's just a very
winning position for black so if asked
you to pause the video here and I will
ask you to pause the video here and try
to find the winning move for black you
would probably very quickly find it so
feel free to do so so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding such a nice forcing line and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the winning move is route capture sin g8
after Queen capture or you don't capture
and then you just lost a piece you don't
really have any other good good
continuations so Queen captures and g8
and now you get a bishop the Queen to f6
chair just picking up the bishop
well and of course official blocks then
you go for Bishop captures captures
captures with check and now wherever you
go either go to the Queen side and
you're getting made it or you go to g2
and then it's Queen if one check King G
three queen G one check King moves
wherever and then you pick up whites
Queen and of course it's a completely
winning position but here instead of
rook to g8 the hunk are played what
appears to be the greatest Queen
sacrifice of all time Queen to f6 check
and it's just this is the position that
Gordon sent me and I was like yeah
that's you're obviously tricking me
there's no way that this happened in an
actual game especially between a between
a 22 2700 player and the 24 3100 player
but this is in fact what happened in the
game Queen to f6 check was played and
now okay where we might ask ourselves
what happens if the Queen is captured
well okay if you capture the Queen then
obviously okay rook captures and g8 and
now Queen captures on f7 with check and
black will either lose the roof or you
have to block with the knight to keep an
eye on the rope here and here you're
just gonna play nicely to black doesn't
have any good moves whatever you play is
pretty much useless you sure you don't
have way of getting your rook anywhere
the knight is stuck here the bishop
doesn't have all that okay this bishops
on a nice diagonal but it's really not
doing anything once this row comes to e1
it's it's game over I mean it's already
game over
but the the point is after Queen to f6
white did not accept the Queen and here
it may be maybe it's just a case of
double blindness maybe it's I don't know
but I mean your friends at the bar and
the library will not believe that this
actually happened they will they will
either think you're tricking them or
that it's some sort of a bullet game
straight out of thread out of an online
game but it's actually played in a
classical game between two very strong
players so it's really just uh III
decided to show it and maybe I'm missing
something obvious maybe it's just I mean
a case of double blindness and blindness
has happened before
between much stronger players and
between well elite players as well but
I've never seen
once such as this one okay you could you
could you know the Avanti Anand miss
Mayton one but they were really low on
the on the clock and it was like an
insane blitz game but here this is a
classical game and even if you you know
clicked the clock with one seconds on
the one second on the clock you still
get a 30 seconds increment so even after
a Queen to f6 if this was the case you
still had 30 seconds to to think about
what you you're gonna do but here white
it did not accept except the Queen white
just moved away from check King be 1 and
this is just amazing and now of course
it's a black that is completely winning
so we into f1 check was played King
daddy - now Quinta f2 check King to d1
and Bishop to d3 threatening just Queen
e2 followed by Queen to c2 checkmate so
the key to prevented this with Queen to
g4 and now we have Queen captures NV -
Queen to f3 going after the bishop but
now just brush up the c2 check and it
was in this position that stavroula so
lucky to resign the game as there is
nothing more to do here you are losing
your g8 Bishop you are losing the rook
on a1 you are losing the knight and Ji
Won everything is just falling apart and
I have no word I have no words on this
game I mean Queen to f6 check this is
this is like if I was making a movie
about chess I would I would choose this
game if it was in a like a magical
kingdom and you know there were monsters
in that movie and and and chess this is
the game that I would show this this is
just beautiful it could be that maybe
maybe why thought that there was
actually Khan for play but I don't know
please help me out in the comments and
and maybe we can get to the bottom of
this or you may be know something more
about about this game that I don't it's
well it is the way this so really really
just a just a weird game but definitely
as far as I've seen the most mysterious
Queen sacrifice in chess history on par
with the Karpov Queen sacrifice against
you this polgár but that was a blindfold
game but this one's even weirder but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would
to thank John Newland Chris Nichol
Felton Tobin Anderson and wait Coleman
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Isle of
Manchester and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and well hoping more things like this
happen in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day